♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
FOR TWO LONG YEARS JAMES COMEY
PLAYED THE ROLE OF THE
AMERICA'S MORAL MARTYR AND FOR
TWO YEARS IT HAD WORKED FOR
HIM.
IN THE CLOSING DAYS OF 2016
YOU WILL REMEMBER, COMEY WAS
LIKELY THE MOST HATED MAN ON
THE AMERICAN LEFT.
THAT BIZARRE PRESS CONFERENCE
HE HELD IN JULY OF THAT YEAR
IN WHICH HE DESCRIBED HILLARY
CLINTON AS LEGALLY INNOCENT
BUT MORALLY GUILTY MAY IN THE
END COST DEMOCRATS THE
ELECTION.
IT'S POSSIBLE.
THEY HATED HIM FOR IT.
LESS THAN A YEAR LATER,
THOUGH, DONALD TRUMP FIRED
JAMES COMEY AS THE F.B.I.
DIRECTOR.
WHATEVER TRUMP DISLIKES,
LIBERALS LOVE SO COMEY IS BACK
IN THE GOOD GRACES AGAIN.
HE TITLED THE BOOK "A HIGHER
LOYALTY."
MEANING THAT HE UNLIKE YOU IS
A MAN OF PRINCIPLE.
ACCOUNTABLE ONLY TO HIS GOD
AND CONSCIENCE.
IN CONTRAST TO YOUR GRUBBY
POLITICAL CONCERNS.
JAMES COMEY IS THE LAST HONEST
MAN IN AMERICA.
HE MAKES THAT POINT EVERY TIME
HE APPEARS IN PUBLIC.
A AS MAN OF INTEGRITY, JAMES
COMEY WOULD LIKE YOU TO KNOW
DESPITE THE FACT HE HAS NO
EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT THE CLAIM,
HE'S CERTAIN THAT VLADIMIR
PUTIN HAS BEEN BLACKMAILING
TRUMP SINCE DAY ONE.
>> I NEVER THOUGHT THE WORDS
WOULD COME OUT OF MY MOUTH BUT
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WITH THE
PROSTITUTES PEEING ON EACH
OTHER IN MOSCOW IN 2013, IT'S
POSSIBLE BUT I DON'T KNOW.
>> Tucker: POSSIBLE.
HE'S NOT SURE.
IT'S POSSIBLE.
THAT IS WHEN YOU RUN THE
F.B.I. YOU DEAL WITH THICKS
THAT ARE POSSIBLE.
EVEN AFTER THE D.O.J.
INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT CAME
OUT, DESTROYING COMEY'S
CREDIBILITIES AND THE CLAIMS
HE FORTED OVER THE YEARS HE
PERSISTED HE PUBLISHED A SMUG
OP-ED IN THE "WASHINGTON POST"
CLAIMING TO BE VINDICATED OF
ALL WRONGDOING.
WHY WOULD JAMES COMEY DO IS A
THAT?
IT'S LIKE HE DIDN'T THINK YOU
HAD THE INTERNET AND COULDN'T
READ THE REPORT FOR HIMSELF.
MAYBE HE'S SO USED TO BEING
TREATED AS UNTOUCHABLE HE
BELIEVED THAT HE WAS.
BUT IN END AS ALWAYS HAPPENS
THE REALITY INTRUDED.
THE I.G. REPORT DIDN'T
ACTUALLY VINDICATE JAMES
COMEY.
INSTEAD IT REVEALED FRIGHTFUL
ABUSE OF POWER FOR THE F.B.I.
THAT HE RAN THAT SHOULD
TERRIFY AMERICANS LEFT, RIGHT
AND CENTER.
ING SPECTER GENERAL HOROWITZ
SUMMED IT UP ON CAPITOL HILL.
WATCH.
>> WE IDENTIFIED SIGNIFICANT
INACCURACIES AND OMISSIONS IN
EACH OF THE APPLICATION.
SEVEN IN THE FIST APPLICATION.
TOTAL OF 17 BY THE FINAL
RENEWAL APPLICATION.
>> Tucker: ONE OMISSION THAT
COULD BE A MISTAKE.
IT HAPPENS.
17 OF THEM?
THAT IS NOT A MISTAKE.
THAT IS EITHER MALICE OR GROSS
INCOMPETENCE OR COMBINATION OF
BOTH.
EITHER WAY IT'S NOT
REASSURING.
IN THE END, SOMEONE AS BELOVED
BY THE NEWS MEDIA AS JAMES
COMEY HAD TO ANSWER FOR THE 17
OMISSIONS.
OVER THE WEEKEND, COMEY
APPEARED ON FOX.
HE SAID THIS ABOUT THE I.G.
REPORT.
>> HE'S RIGHT, I WAS WRONG.
I WAS OVERCONFIDENT IN THE
PROCEDURES THAT THE F.B.I. AND
JUSTICE HAD BUILT OVER 20
YEARS.
I THOUGHT THEY WERE ROBUST
ENOUGH.
IT'S INCREDIBLY HARD TO GET A
FISA.
I WAS OVER CONFIDENT IN THOSE.
HE IS RIGHT.
THERE WERE SLOPPINESS.
17 THINGS THAT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN IN APPLICATION OR DISCUSS
AND CHARACTERIZED DIFFERENTLY.
IT WAS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
SO HE IS RIGHT, I WAS WRONG.
>> Tucker: IT'S INCREDIBLY
HARD TO GET A FISA.
REALLY?
HOW INCREDIBLY HARD IS IT, JIM
COMEY?
HOW MANY HAVE BEEN TURNED DOWN
IN THE PAST 15 YEAR?
YOU DON'T HAVE THE NUMBERS DO
YOU?
NOT MANY IS THE REAL ANSWER.
BUT THAT WASN'T EVEN THE MOST
DAMNING PART OF THE INTERVIEW
WITH THAT LIAR YOU JUST SAW.
AT ONE POINT JIM COMEY WAS
ASKED IF LYING TO FISA COURT
TO SPY ON AMERICAN CITIZEN
MIGHT MERIT PROFESSIONAL
CONSEQUENCES.
HERE IS HOW HE RESPONDED.
>> IF YOU WERE STILL THERE AND
ALL OF THIS CAME OUT AND IT
TURNED OUT IT HAPPENED ON YOUR
WATCH, WOULD YOU RESIGN?
>> NO, I DON'T THINK SO.
THERE WERE MORE MISTAKES MORE
CONSEQUENCE
CONSEQUENCIAL THIS IN MY
TENURE AND THE IMPORTANT THING
IS TO BE TRANSPARENT ABOUT IT.
>> Tucker: THINK ABOUT IT.
THERE WERE WORSE MISTAKES THAN
KNOWINGLY USING PARTISAN LIES
TO SPY ON AMERICAN CITIZEN BUT
JIM COMEY WON'T TELL YOU WHAT
THEY ARE BECAUSE HE BELIEVES
IN TRANSPARENCY.
DID YOU CATCH ALL THAT?
THAT WAS ALL IN ONE SENTENCE,
BY THE WAY.
SENTENCE THAT CONTRADICTS
ITSELF.
DID ANYONE NOTICE?
NOBODY SEEMED TO.
WE NEED NEW INSPECTOR GENERAL
TO FIND OUT WHAT HE IS TALKING